oh I know that oh you know yeah yeah oh
I've seen this
Oh looks like a cut but it's not I know
and like how's the camera guy now
flipping around hello everyone we are
back with another stuntman react we're
here with Eric Linden a very experienced
and wise stuntman stunt coordinator it's
not Lois stunt Lord we prefer the term
stunt lord this is your reel this is my
really there's probably really good for
us to react you that's me in a Bentley
commercial ok Westworld ah no I didn't
recognize you in that oh yeah me run in
my underwear that's you right there yeah
people always say that even though it's
like my real and like yes it's me that
was a hit oh you know yeah yeah we did
some good stuff in your video I am
honored that so our videos are in your
reel yeah oh yeah there's a lot of my
other buddies that have come and you
know worked with you guys and that's in
their reels like every time we're we're
with you guys we do like legit stuff
that's so cool vGHS we're in that truck
you breeding that truck he has it
flipped for the longest time you wanted
to do a car flip I know that was my
first one I'm so pumped and then I got
to crash a bunch of cars after that nice
oh my god I had the GoPro footage of me
in it really oh yeah it just goes
so you're just in there like you hope
was a full CG bull yeah
but they had real bowls there everything
was on motion controlled cameras yeah
they would run the Bulls through the
scene nice and so it was a locked-off
corridor and they let him run out the
other side of the stage and then we'd go
in there and do the reactions to it
so how do you set somebody on fire
what's it like being in a fire suit
being in a fire suit is absolutely
miserable first of all because you're
completely freezing yeah yeah yeah
though all the gel that goes into the
clothes it's like embedded into the
clothes which are fireproof clothing
yeah it causes your body heat to get
sucked into the gel but you know it
creates a barrier between you and the
fire so you don't really feel the fire
actually by the time you're ready to go
you are so freezing cold that you're
like please set me on fire really yeah
you're just like you want to be that's
the magic huh make them want it and then
it's all good yeah
wait don't just to hold your breath you
depending on the burn but yes it's a
good idea to hold your perhaps you
should light him on fire sometime oh
yeah down are you really down for that
I'm a hundred percent down to get lit on
fire it's happening for real subscribe
so that you can see it so that you can
see Renan catch me on fire this guy for
Red Bull he's up like 200 feet gets lit
on fire smashes through a window and
falls like 200 feet into an air bag that
they had to cook they had to build a
special air bag to be able to go this
high up in there and then wait for the
air bag to deflate and put him out and
he's holding his breath all the time the
whole time it's insane
he's so high up and he's like flipping
and turning as he does it oh my god you
this is something you'd have a wire for
he even did it practically that's nuts
it's so high up you know he had to work
work up to it like who knows how many
times he did the jump but you know he
had to do like 100 feet than 150 feet
and then on the day we'll have add the
fire element into it and the window he
smashed through a window when it comes
to air bags you especially at this
height you need to land flat on your
back if you were to land on your head
you're not gonna make it if you land on
your feet you're gonna break a leg not
to mention if you don't kind of land
mostly flat it's gonna whip you down
after your feet tap and knock you out
break your neck I mean it down at that
height you know
how bad it could be and then you see all
the guys on the outside like yanking the
bag down trying to get it to deflate so
they can get to him and put him out look
at that
he's like rolling off the side to get to
them still on fire so he kind of had to
take a second to catch his breath but
he's fine
Wow I mean I know the guy he's he's
unbelievable
I worked with him one time and he was
doing a high fall it is about 30 40 feet
and I was like oh hey Bob and like
you're doing that high fall today right
and he goes that ain't high fall I'm
like coming from you that's that's right
because they don't even do this anymore
like nobody jumps that high like you
would definitely be on the water huh
like the gnarliest guy out there right
now I was like Tom Cruise doing that
type of stuff suit up the widow is
meeting lark in 30 minutes the thing
about the skydive is Tom Cruise
literally went and learned how to halo
jump which is unbelievable like you have
to use oxygen and a phenomenal stunt
just unbelievable achievement but they
completely ruined it by putting in CG
clouds and CG lightning bolts I felt
like that they could have achieved the
same story point without putting any CG
in it at all yeah cuz it does look like
a green-screen
kind of thing you don't know and only
because of the lightning but you might
as well be on a green screen if gonna
throw up that much Viet exum here we go
this camera guy though just camera guy
it looks like a cut but it's not know
and he has to hit the focal distance
here I know and like how's the camera
guy now flipping around it gets goofy
now because of the lightning yeah I mean
this but that but this is all him now
it's all whole time yeah you can tell
like he's done this so many times he's
chillin it's just the fact that he's
able to do that with the precision with
the camera as well let alone just being
able to do it I know it's like it's
super easy to bump into somebody and
like break your arm or even knock
yourself out
totally like that when he misses this
guy like if you were to hit him at this
speed he could have gotten injured for
sure yeah see how they fog up cavils uh
yeah helmet so that they can't tell it's
not him Oh smart yeah
we that that's awesome oh dude this
lightning I've grabbed this landing oh
my god
Oh let's go back and let's talk about it
it's what you think there's a cut rate
as they go through the clouds I think
there's probably two hidden cuts I know
they did the whole sequence in freefall
yeah
from the way it looks it looks like
they're using a couple different takes
to put together still doesn't take away
from the fact that least did like ten
halo jumps to make it happen but that's
a single take from the plane to here
he's come right up to the camera to be
at a certain focal distance because the
cameras already set to that focal
distance I know that did you try that a
couple times he has to come right to
that point takes precision that's
probably cut right there yeah that's
probably a cut here but is he throwing
his body around like that yeah yes
the thing is like yeah if you're gonna
go through all this effort to show the
audience that you're doing this crazy
stunt that's like super dangerous super
high intensity but you throw in all that
CG lightning in clouds it's like it
makes it all feel fake again it might as
well just be a cartoon at that well and
the audience is so smart now when it
comes that stuff that they kind of it
does make the rest of it feel fake cut
because that's awesome yeah that looks
like a cub and then the ground is a CG
now that sounds like the ground itself
is real but they added the lights and
stuff to make it feel like they're over
a city before the destination with a
jumping - dude I just I just feel bad
for the roto artists on this having a
paint out the motion blur pant legs and
everything so Aaron do they have guys
are they tapped in with like radio
saying hey guys you're at this altitude
you're at this altitude they could
easily be in the scene right and get
carried away with the scene and not be
focusing on like how much further they
have left I'm sure they're talking to
him the entire time and not to mention
there's probably what eight ten guys off
doing this at the exact same time they
do have to get guys are expert skydivers
that can operate a camera I know this
guy who's jumping in front of Tom Cruise
literally has the camera strapped to the
top of his helmet do you think he has
like like something over like one eye so
you can see what I see in the camera
yeah man like that futuristic Terminator
vision like the little screen yeah you
want to see the highest box jump I've
ever seen oh I've seen this
this is unbelievable like this guy right
now he's he's not a hundred percent sure
he's again
make it like this this might be it oh my
god because it's some point it's too low
to pull the chute like if you miss
you're done oh my god oh god that's more
than half go in face-first or is he like
flaring oh looks like he eats it
this is headfirst berries into the boxes
go Gary
you got it Gary don't other sizes a dead
Gary yeah in my opinion this is what my
favorite stunts of all time like I love
it when stunts represent something that
you could actually do in real life you
know super fantastical and hard to pull
off so now there's a plane going out
this runway with no one in it and James
Bond is going to try to catch up to it
and get into it
it's been awhile holiness but that's
they kind of ruined the illusion by
cutting to this shot
yeah that's not I feel like that's fake
dude well cut yeah of course it's inside
the airplane yeah I don't think he made
it into the airplane though no in the
actual stunt they do the whole they take
the whole thing hold on it
yeah it's holding that for one shot
would be ruined
I know it's like because now it doesn't
feel that special but like knowing that
they drove an airplane off the runway
had a guy chase on a motorcycle jump off
the motorcycle catch up to the plane get
in the plane and fly away but they don't
really show it I would have kept that
the whole time just in that one shot
you're taking the stunt guy on the
bridge it gets hit by the car and all
the water oh my god do you know if you
can barely see it you can barely see
your seat again oh this is back when
they really couldn't do it outside of
you oh my god
and then clears the railing what a sad I
would you snuck real that would you put
that in turn around zoom in I mean
that's fun I mean he really did that was
unbelievable how do you even go about
doing something like that so he had it
right there when he hits the car the car
kind of has to stomp the gas a little
bit to get him to really whip off of it
it was too type of car hits and one is
you get hit and you go up onto the glass
and then they stomp the brake and you
get spit off or you roll up onto the
glass and they stop the gas and you go
up and over it huh oh that's amazing I
mean wow thank you so much for watching
this stuntman reacts to stunts sorry I'm
glad again
hey dude thank you so Martha thank you
so much it's like Jim Carrey's over here
making you go
thank you all for watching this video I
hope you've enjoyed this insight into
the world of stunts it's such a
fascinating unique craft and honestly
one of my favorite parts about
filmmaking Eric thank you so much for
joining us yeah now if we wanted to
follow what you've been up to what's the
best way for us to do that you can find
me anywhere on Instagram Twitter all
that stuff under Eric Linden